votre bilan c'est la violence ça suffit
policier brûlé journaliste frappé
manifestants mutilés les coupables c'est
vous nous apportons notre soutien à tous
les blessés vous opposez le peuple au
peuple pas nous
vous vouliez tourner la page des
retraites c'est raté vous reportez tous
vos projets de loi vous ne savez plus où
vous allez la Cinquième République
permet d'agir sans le peuple et contre
lui elle n'est plus légitime en bafouant
ses principes républicains vous
accélérez sa chute et la vôtre alors oui
ah bah Macron est la mauvaise République
vive la Constituante et la Sixième
République ici c'est la France celle
d'un peuple insoumis dont la nation
s'est fondée par une révolution on ne
fait pas taire le peuple on l'écoute on
ne le méprise pas on le respecte on ne
leur imprime pas on lui obéit je
regrette très sincèrement monsieur le
député que pour la première question au
gouvernement après des violences
absolument inacceptables qui ont blessé
405 policiers et gendarmes hier
policier dans ta policier qui aurait pu
comme chacun a vu à sa télévision mourir
parce qu'on envoie un cocktail Molotov
sur sa tête et qui les brûlé au deuxième
degré que vous n'ayez pas un mot pour
eux pour ces pères et mère de famille
démontre votre humanisme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elles ont surtout pour cible les forces
de l'ordre
[Musique]
hier plus de 400 policiers et gendarmes
ont été blessés dont certains
grièvements les images que nous avons vu
notamment celle d'un policier brûlé par
un cocktail Molotov sont insupportables
et illustrent qu'un nouveau palier a été
franchi dans la violence